K
YOU.
>> CITY WILL STOCKS, DOWN SEVEN
58%.
THE WASHINGTON JOURNAL SAYS THE
COMPANY IS ABOUT TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY AFTER DIFFERENT
POINTING SUMMER SALES.
BLAMED ON A SLATE OF FILMS.
PAULA MONICA IS WITH ME.
PAUL, LISTEN FIRST OF ALL TWO
AT THIS CEO TOLD ME WHEN WE
INTERVIEWED HIM A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO.
THE CEO ADMITTED THAT THINGS
WERE DIFFICULT.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID, AND YOU
TAKE IT FROM THERE.
>> I THINK ONE THING THAT WE
GOT FROM COVID, AND OUR
INDUSTRY REALLY SUFFERED A LOT
AS EVERYONE, KNOWS BUT THE ONE
POSITIVE THING THAT WE'VE GOT
FROM COVID IS THAT THE STUDIOS
HAVE TIME TO EXPERIMENT AROUND
THE WINDOW, IT WAS SUCH A BIG
ISSUE.
TO EVERYONE IT'S NOW CLEAR THAT
THE BEST WAY TO MAXIMIZE AN
INCOME FROM A MOVIE, MOVIES
FROM A CERTAIN DEGREE OF BOX
OFFICE, TO MAXIMIZE THIS, YOU
HAVE TO GO FIRST TO THE CINEMAS
AND GO TO THE OTHER PLATFORMS.
THIS IS THE WAY TO DO IT.
>> SO, PAUL, WHAT'S YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SITUATION,
NOW?
>> YEAH, I THINK, RICHARD, EVEN
THOUGH AS THE CNN WORLD CEO
SAID, THE STUDIOS HAVE
RECOGNIZED THAT MOVIE THEATERS
ARE STILL IMPORTANT.
YOU CAN'T JUST PUT EVERYTHING
ON STREAMING, THAT COMPANIES
LIKE DISNEY AND PARAMOUNT, OUR
PARENT COMPANY, WARNER BROTHERS,
THEY'RE ALSO TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WET MOVIES TO MAKE SENSE
FOR THE BIG BLOCKBUSTER
EXPERIENCE?
AND WHAT COULD GO DO STREAMING?
THERE'S ONLY A HANDFUL OF
MOVIES THAT PEOPLE WILL REALLY
FLOCK TO SEE AN OPENING
WEEKEND.
THIS TURF OF BLOCKBUSTERS IS
HURTING A COMPANY LIKE SIN
WORLD, WHICH RUNS REGAL, --
AMC WHICH IS TAKEN ON A LIFE OF
EXAM, IT SHARES ARE STRUGGLING
TODAY BECAUSE OF THESE REPORTS.
YOU HAVE SAID, AMERICA'S
SIMILARLY NAMED COMPANY,
THEY'RE DOWN TODAY.
IMAX IS DOWN.
INVESTORS RECOGNIZE THAT THE
MOVIE THEATER BUSINESS IS
CHALLENGED BECAUSE YOU CAN ONLY
HAVE SO MANY MOVIES LIKE
SPIDER-MAN AND LIKE THOR.
THOSE MARVEL MOVIES THAT PEOPLE
ARE GONNA GO SEE OPENING
WEEKEND.
WILL THEY GO SEE THEM AGAIN?
THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION.
>> RIGHT, BUT YOU KNOW, YOU
DON'T HAVE THE POLICY THAT HER
OWN CEO HAS BROUGHT IN AND
WARNER BROTHERS DISCOVERY,
WHICH IS ONE THAT SAYS --
THEY PENCIL --
CANCELED BAT GIRL FOR EXAMPLE,
SOME MOVIES ARE MADE FOR THE
BIG SCREEN.
AND THEY MUST BE MADE FOR THE
BIG SCREEN WITH ATTENDANT
BUDGETS, RATHER THAN FOR THE
STREAMING SERVICES.
THAT HAS SOME WAY, IF YOU WILL,
TO FLESH OUT AND FALL OUT.
>> YEAH, I THINK YOU'RE
DEFINITELY RIGHT, RICHARD.
THERE CLEARLY WILL STILL BE
EVENT DRIVEN MOVIES THAT PEOPLE
WILL WANT TO SEE IN A COMMUNAL
ATMOSPHERE.
FOR THE MOST PART, MOST
FILMGOERS ARE NO LONGER AS
WORRIED ABOUT THE PANDEMIC.
OBVIOUSLY MANY OF THE MOVIE
THEATER CHAINS, SOME OF THEM
STILL HAVE PEOPLE WEARING
MASKS.
OTHERS NOT SO MUCH.
BUT CLEARLY WE HAVE A SCENARIO
WHERE WE'RE ALSO PRESSED FOR
TIME.
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
ENTERTAINMENT OPTIONS THAT ARE
OUT THERE.
EVEN IF MOVIES ARE DEBUTING
ONLY IN THEATERS FIRST, WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF EVENT
DRIVEN TV SHOWS THAT ARE ON
STREAMING PLATFORMS, ON CABLE
NETWORKS, THAT PEOPLE MAY
CHOOSE, YOU KNOW --
I DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO GO
SEE THIS BLOCKBUSTER MOVIE THIS
WEEKEND, I'M GOING TO STAY HOME
INSTEAD AND BINGE-WATCH AN
ENTIRE SEASON OF A NEW SHOW
OVER AN EIGHT-HOUR PERIOD.